[Music]
bro you ever walk in a joint and they're
surprised to see you to see a human oh
yes
yeah
yo come here real quick look look you
know dude What's your name
so what's up where you been dog who the
[__] are you like watching a movie on an
iPad yo yo literally yeah yeah I walked
in and it was hot in there yeah it was
musty
yeah absolutely a lot of places are
really better in Canada like yeah we got
that real meat man okay that Real
Canadian Farms oh America bro dude we're
eating plastic and yeah and it's like
you know you see the tick tocks and
there you are still just yeah dude I was
talking about how like Diet Coke isn't
in Europe
I'm like oh maybe it's the amount of
like aspartame or something but then
Spock was like it's probably because the
the name diet is in the drink and I'm
like that is kind of crazy to have Diet
like as part of a drink name yeah
like the Europeans like no you don't get
to say that yeah yeah you're like Diet
wine yeah diet wine yeah yeah
true you know we're gonna get diet candy
like just get the [__] candy yeah
yeah
I'm watching it yeah you're not sure
I got the diet chocolate syrup
diet [__] three-layer cheesecake
if I get a diet chocolate cake
look down man you ever ordered some [__]
and just look away just don't even make
eye contact with them yeah it was like a
dirty Diet you're down bad and [__] life
ain't going how you like it you hit the
Wendy's yeah let me get yeah meals
one drink
I think you pull your honey up you're
like
yeah I didn't want to see you I love man
you gotta look them in the island you
ask them for the sauce man it's always
getting the bag first oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah you're not gonna yeah there's one
day I had to open the window with the
two fingers yeah
I
five of them I was at McDonald's and I
asked her a barbecue and see inside she
said but you didn't get no nuggets I
felt stupid trying to say no I'm just
going to dip the burger
that's so funny she's judging you it
doesn't make sense
what would you use these dips for even
um
[Laughter]
did I not get nuggets
can I get nuggets
yeah no bro you drive around you try to
you try to change your voice
let me get the nuggets with barbecue
sauce no nuggets
excuse me snack is no nuggets barking
sauce though please
can you put my order hold the nuggets
I got a zero piece nugget with uh
I'm gonna do it
look at the diet zero nuggets
all right nuggets zero of them
you ever place a bigger order because
you don't want your delivery man just
carrying like one sandwich
but no like you're not gonna bring me
one Burger because you feel bad yeah I'm
gonna make it work this guy's getting in
his car he's got 10.
one sauce you ever guess yes
yeah yeah thanks and then you don't tip
him and his priorities just Jay's hand
coming out the door thank you
yo covet made me just like
I still do this they'll come to drop it
off and watch them to the people and
[__] yeah it drops it off okay walks
away
elevator opens
elevator closes
bro do you get embarrassed when you
order from the two places and they sync
up yes yeah you're like I was dominoes
yeah literally the other night man yeah
the wings came first the other day and
then I was like looking on the tracker
and I saw the other one coming up the
hill I'm like yo
fail bounce dude
well no because I felt like a clown
because it was like a weird timing
because I I was going to get the bag of
wings and the guy pulled up I'm like ah
it's like close the door and then the
dude walks up with the pizza and I could
tell he was calculating he's like it's
like I just saw you close the door yeah
you saw me we made eye contact no no no
no no he's sorry he saw the wings and he
probably saw like my [__] yeah he
probably like felt my air yeah you know
no no the wings were on the porch but I
think he like might have heard me try to
grab him
let me close it yeah it just like kind
of gave up because I saw like the like
the I saw the front of the car kind of
roll up
yeah so then he gets her you play it
cool like oh [__] yeah yeah
no no I just did it ordered These Wings
I think they showed up
where'd These Wings come from no because
then he'll do the awkward things like I
could take them but yeah well no
actually you know how long they've been
here yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
what kind of order is this what kind of
psycho do that
[__] disgusting dude you definitely
don't
no so then the guy the pizza is walking
up and I could tell I could like you
like hear him through the door like I
hear his brain like putting it together
like oh
you're so sick yeah you dirty [__] we
think High Caliber chefs are ordering
like sneaky dirty pizzas yeah shameful
pizzas for sure just leave it on the
doorstep there yeah yeah yeah
you might know from the instructions I'm
like let's see three seconds
before damn Michelin star Chef coding
his voice to order his diet nuggets
[Laughter]
Gordon Ramsay
no no no no no no no no no it's not
yeah who else is a Michelin star chef
I thought he was gonna hand him out
these days man yeah my house they got
their Michelin star no they deserve it
they should have deserve that [__] yeah
yeah
my Egyptian Place meanwhile lead where
they have the guy yeah
it's like a nice place yeah I literally
have a picture meanwhile lead were
eating brunch when they got the the girl
comes and she drops off the star she's
like oh wait sorry yeah
before we went yeah yeah yeah yeah they
weren't expecting it didn't no they just
popped up
they don't tell you right someone like
they told me the story like crazy they
pop up like there's a regular person it
could be anyone man that's kind of scary
man
no literally
it might be him they're saying that was
just a random guy that pulled up yeah
there it is that was the same day all
the way to the left uh
uh yeah right there
if you keep scrolling you'll probably
find my picture up there too
I'm telling you man
but uh yeah it was just a random uh guy
that pulled up and uh he he ordered some
dishes and then walked away and then she
came in dropped off said yeah that that
one guy and described him he's like yeah
I was a Judge Joe that [__] slap yeah
that [__] so these guys just eat good
and that's like their that's their job
credentials yeah we should just do that
we should just make stars just make us
pretend to be part of Michelin yeah and
go eat place and be like yo
that
dip was crazy